this is
absolute anti-racial
propaganda Congress you know they have
these hearings and mostly in these
hearings it's people being exposed to be
complete idiots and nothing really
happens afterwards uh but here is a
really interesting video this is
Congressman Greg Murray uh talking to
the Secretary of the Smithsonian Lonnie
G Bunch
III and you will see how anti-white woke
propaganda has even leaked into the
Smithsonian Joy this is in the
Smithsonian assumptions about white
culture and it says rugged individualism
family structure emphasis on scientific
method history Protestant work ethic
religion no tolerance from deviation
from a single God concept this is
absolute anti-racial
propaganda why would anything like this
be in the Smithsonian Institute now it's
my understanding what I think you're
seeing I can't really see it is you
should be very well versed in this you
were the head of the Smithsonian at the
time let me explain what it is is there
was a document that is the whiteness
document that was put up online that I
took down immediately because I think
that the document itself was wrong and
flawed I do think however it's important
for the Smithsonian to help the country
grapple with questions of race so I'm
not going to run away from that but I
agree with you very much that that
document is not the kind of document
that should be at the Smithsonian and if
it's what I think it is I pulled that
down how does this help us with
race it does is divide us this is
divisive language saying that white
people own any we don't tolerate any
deviation except a single God
concept how is that helpful I don't
understand that I I I wish someone could
explain that to me I want to give the
the head of the Smithsonian credit for
just a moment which is that they did
actually take that document down and and
what he said related to the Smithsonian
and and any Museum that it's relevant
dealing with the issues of race in an
honest way would be just fine right like
that's like a kid in a public school
learning about race learning about an
honest assessment of History nobody's
debating that the reason I'm showing you
that is the fact that that document was
part of a Smithsonian exhibition that it
was on their website that it got in
there in the first place tells you all
you need to know about the people that
are are running the Smithsonian it tells
you all you need to know about again how
this thing has infected all of our
institutions so yes it is just fine that
you took it down that you did the right
thing when you were exposed right but
the fact that that got there that kids
learned from that imagine you're a white
kid at the Smithsonian with your class
and you walk into the Smithsonian you
walk into any Museum where they're where
they're teaching any of this nonsense
and You by the nature of your skin color
are the guilty one and then let's Flash
Forward a little bit so now you're
taught that you're in your sixth seventh
grade you go to the Smithsonian and you
read about how basically you're a white
supremacist and your ancestors were all
evil and everything else now you're in
high school and you're applying for
colleges and suddenly you realize that
it's going to be much harder for you to
get into a college because you're white
and because Equity has now been pushed
into all of these colleges uh they're
going to take the black kid instead of
you but you make it into some school not
a school that you should have got into
you make it into some other school
because they're discriminating against
you as a white person or a Jewish person
or they're by the way they're doing it
to Asians too I don't think woo realizes
that in Boston but now it's a little
also harder to get into grad school or
it's a little harder to get that job at
that company because they have a de eii
uh program in their in their system as
well do you see how this could lead to
an actual collapse of the entire
American system when you take out
meritocracy when you take out believing
that the individual is the most
important thing and you unearth all of
the old racism you just repackage the
racism that we all got rid
of